[Music]
another week another GPU release it
seems this time around we're checking
out the new radian rx460 the GPU for
gamers that aren't willing to sacrifice
everything else in their life for the
sake of high resolution Ultra quality
gameplay based on Polaris 11 the rx460
will likely be the most affordable
gaming GPU AMD release in
2016 unfortunately due to timing I don't
actually know the MSRP for the rx460 has
AMD yet to release that information as
I'm putting this review together there
are 3 days to go before the official
release and unfortunately I can't wait
until the last minute to finalize
everything if you're watching this on
launch day the 8th I'm currently away in
Bangkok attending an Nvidia launch event
for a new unnamed high and product which
I'll no doubt be filling you guys in on
shortly so keep your eye out for a video
later this week covering the event and
any other Shenanigans I get up to while
staying in Bankok although I don't know
the official MSRP I can take an educated
guess based on my findings and I'll do
so in the final stages of this review
once again I'll be using my new sub $200
graphics card testing rig powered by a
modestly clocked skylet core I3 6100t
processor this system does a good job of
representing the kind of rigs Gamers
purchasing the affordable graphics cards
will likely be running the system is
built into the fractal design defined
Nan and features a GB z170n Wi-Fi
motherboard the only unrealistic
Hardware used is a 16 GB ddr4 memory kit
a 2 TB SSD and an 850 W power supply the
2 TB SD has been used simply because I
need to install a heap of games for
testing and 850 wat power supply simply
because I had it spare unfortunately as
was the case with the rx470 review I had
very limited time to get this review
done so again just 12 games have been
tested at one resolution though it is
the extremely popular 1080p res in the
coming weeks I'll be preparing a few
rx470 and rx460 partner card reviews and
this is where I'll focus on overclocking
performance although I'm using a factory
overclock Sapphire rx460 for testing
it's been underclocked to meet the
reference AMD clock specification ific
ations this has been done to keep the
results Fair as all other cars tested
have also been done at the reference AMD
and Nvidia specifications okay so that
gets the important stuff out of the way
let's get to the results shall we we'll
kick off things again with Superman's
somehow worthy foe here the 460 produced
47 frames per second with a minimum of
33 this was right around the performance
of the Gen 1 r7370 and 45% slower than
the rx470 this is honestly a slightly
bigger Gap than I'd expected between
these two cards for 750 Ti uses however
it's a big step up and you stand to gain
34% performance in this game next up is
Star Wars Battlefront and here the 460
red 53 FPS on the high quality setting
at 1080p this time it was a little
closer to the recently released 470
coming in at 40% slower was also 40%
faster than the 750 Ti Black Ops 3 was
very playable on the high quality
setting with anti- aine disabled the 460
was good for 54 FPS and a 47 FPS minimum
133% faster than the r7370 which made 48
fps performance was virtually on par
with the gtx950 as the 460 was 2% faster
next I tested Doom in Vulcan with the
ultra quality preset and AA disabled the
460 made a healthy 81 FPS here and was a
considerable 62% faster than the 750 Ti
Vulcan also allowed the 460 to shoot
ahead of the 950 by 133% but it was 46%
behind the 470 I dialed mirror edge
Catalyst down to medium for these cards
and here the 460 managed 50 FPS this was
28% faster than the 750 Ti which was one
of the closer margins seen between these
cards the 460 was also with in 32% of
the 470 and 36% of the 480 the hardware
friendly AAA title OverWatch was next
and at 1080p on Ultra you can expect
around 73 FPS from the 460 this seems
really good but it was only 3% faster
than the 370 and was 5% slower than 750
Ti this is the only game where the 750
Ti had a slight Edge Far Cry Primal is a
demanding game and here we found that on
the high quality setting the 460 could
produce 42 FPS this is 24% more than the
750 Ti 9% less than the GTX 950 and 30
30% less than the I9 380 in that Lord of
the Rings themed game the 460 made 43
FPS on the ultra quality setting which
isn't bad this was 50% less than the
rx480 and 10% less than the gtx950
performance was pretty much on par with
the 370 though with the 460 managing
just a single extra frame interestingly
though the 460 had a much higher minimum
frame rate the division is another
demanding game and here the 460 could
make 39 FPS on average this is just
about on par with the GTX 950 and 8%
faster than the 370 750 Ti users can
expect a 39% performance boost in this
game at 1080p I tested rise of the Tomb
Raider in its direct X12 mode with a
very high quality setting and the 460
produced 49 frames per second this was
slightly higher than the 370 and 29%
faster than the 750 Ti Total War
Warhammer was also run through its
direct X12 test and the 460s performance
was pretty decent it beat the 370 by a
solid 15% and the 950 by 31% was also a
little closer to the 470 and 480 than it
typically has been this time within 37
and 39% respectively the last game I
looked at was The Witcher 3 wild Hunt
here the 460 was on par with the 950
with a 40 FPS average was also 38%
faster than the 750 Ti and 8% faster
than the 370 I recorded the total system
power consumption after 20 minutes of
gameplay on average the RX 460
configuration consume 139 Watts which is
good and certainly a step forward for
AMD however it's not wildly impressive
when you compare it to the previous
generations GTX 950 which was basically
on part performance- wise overall but
only used more watts it's obviously
important to note that the card tested
is not in fact a reference card but
Sapphire's Nitro Edition when it comes
to power consumption and temperatures
the cooler looks pretty big on this
thing but interestingly it still ran at
75° the card was virtually dead silent
though so obviously this could be
improved with a more aggressive fan
curve well there you have it this
lower-end card was never going to be a
world beater so our overall opinion is
very much going to be price dependent
unfortunately at this point I don't have
the pricing information as mentioned
before we make any conclusions and
speculate on price let's take a look at
how this card compared directly with
some of its competition the RX 460 was
overall 41% slower than the Big Brother
470 and I guess this was a little more
of a gap than I was expecting I'm
definitely hoping now that this card
comes in around 40% cheaper compared to
the r7370 the performance was really
quite close there's only a couple of
outliers being Far Cry Cod and Total
Wars direct X12 test aside from these
you shouldn't expect too much difference
between these two cards and the average
overall was 3.6% in favor of the rx460
overall the performance was on par with
the GTX 9950 though there's certainly
some decent swings either way Total Wars
direct X12 test was a massive outlier
and here the 460 was 31% faster there
were some games that favored the 950
quite considerably too including
OverWatch Tomb Raider and direct X12
curiously and Far Cry the results were
fairly consistent in comparison to the
r9380 overall there's a 30% deficit to
the popular 380 and it would be
interesting to Crunch the numbers and
see how the cost per frame works out
compared to the GTX 960 the rx460 was
17% slower on average results were also
fairly consistent here and again it will
be interesting to see the cost per Frame
data the RX 460 is shaping up as a solid
upgrade for users of the 750 Ti the
average Improvement scene was 33.6% and
Vulcan allowed the 460 to shoot ahead by
a massive 62% I'm still really looking
forward to being able to compare all of
these cards with other games that
utilize lowlevel API the only game we
users are better off with the 750 Ti is
OverWatch where the 460 was 5% slower so
as I talked about earlier the success of
this card will certainly come down to
pricing
given what we've seen here I expect the
rx460 to cost around $110 at that price
it comes at a similar cost per frame as
the rx470 if it does end up being the
correct price it means that when
compared to the previous generation
r7370 which I might add was a first
generation GCM part budget gamers are
getting a slightly more efficient
graphics card and saving $40 to $50 in
the process overall the radiant RX 460
is a competent 1080p gaming solution
providing you willing to dial down the
quality settings little in the more
extreme AAA titles what do you guys
think let me know in the comments like
you always do I'm your host M as always
and I'll see you guys next time
YouTubers like me depend on your support
to continue improving the quality and
content of our videos to support the
channel directly consider becoming a
patron to also get access to a heap of
cool rewards and exclusive giveaways
also don't forget you can check prices
and buy the products I looked at in this
video through the Amazon links in the
video description below thank you kindly
for supporting me and the hardware unbox
Channel it means a lot to me and I
really do appreciate it and in return
I'll continue to work as hard as I can
to keep producing the content you
enjoy